si era tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa dj oggi siamo
ritornati per la mia gioia geometri dash
subzero ho preso start facciamo l'inizio
così riscaldamento non si è partito al
di là di narcos è la madonna
porca vacca quattro divisioni pensavo
che se gesù cristo di comanda ciò detto
mica facciamola cagata il primo livello
il tutorial da un cazzo difficilissimo
c'è mischia pre fichissimo ragazze
geniale st canzoncina rispetto agli
altri media
forse è meglio che sto zitta
[Musica]
maronna locarno nati da te nato il
nostro livello qua c'è la faccina felice
della serie è una stronzata pensa agli
altri gli altri due che cosa sono
non lo voglio neanche sapere sto facendo
quello che con la faccina verde per
carità di dio
[Musica]
porca eva morta dai ma edizione è
difficilissimo prima che la cosa bella è
che siccome i miei vi dove con un sacco
misti ci sono i campioni di geometri
dash che puntualmente mi scrivono nei
commenti e mathis carl froch idea che
guarda a fan cuore expert mode attivata
[Musica]
a l
porca vacca morto porco ero arrivato lì
maledizione mancava un saltino stupido
cioè come ho fatto a sbagliare dai una
cagata incredibile
[Musica]
ora una nota perché ho fatto tutto il
casino poi una cagata incredibile mi
butta giù ma che idiota un posto essere
così stupido santo giusti ma dai ma che
qatar norme poi tutti noi che non siamo
siamo a un terzo siamo arrivati cioè
siamo un terzo di tutto il livello
niente ok mica pensavo lato la peggio
cosa pensavo all'apocalisse adesso aiuto
perché ho parlato perché conosco il sito
e nel mondo della vita
sì ma che cazzo ragazzi sto pezzo prima
che parta il troppo mi prende di un male
ma cosa si può vedere ma cos'è quanto
difficile aiuto vabbè mi chiamo la
navicella ma mi chiama richiama state ma
stiamo scherzando
non chiedete un po troppo cioè non sono
una persona so io è i video non tutti
gli eroi portano il mantello il vostro
porta una bandana brutta
[Musica]
aiuto arriva arriva arriva veloce che
supermario
[Musica]
porca vacca gente buona
ok ci siamo di nuovo
e devo fare qua
[Musica]
no no no come come aiuto come o come
dovevo farlo
dai dai mi chiamo fatta loro incredibile
ci stavo riuscendo la prima volta cosa
devo fare la non potevo saltare fini
così una d'aiuto raga non ho capito c'è
un
[Musica]
cioè io sono riuscito a schiantarmi sono
riuscito a schiantarmi sul porco il
pietro di soffitto preciso giocato
scrittrice di guardare dentro
e vabbè minchia
[Musica]
bach a vedere chi so much for this love
sì si può
james yoo fan page o più in george video
come sono contento di aver giocato starò
va beh va beh ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto come se sinceramente mi piace
anche loris ovviamente sono stati ci
siete vi e non ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]